[Music]
local firefighters are in lake tahoe
helping tackle the growing cal door fire
they spoke to eight news now reporter
victoria saha they tell her they're
preparing for the worst but they're
hoping for the best
right now the fire is only 20 percent
contained and it's just getting worse
3500 firefighters from across the
country are out there to help with the
blaze including two of our departments
here in southern nevada the fire started
two weeks ago
these are images of the impact the
calder fire is having on surrounding
towns smoke so thick you can barely see
the sun it's just a glimpse of what
crews and residents out there are
dealing with the north las vegas fire
department has six of their men helping
local fire departments out when you look
up into the sky you can barely barely
see the sun it's just this tiny little
dot that's
you know you can only like sort of see
it through the through the smoke the
fire has now spread to more than two
hundred 000 acres ripping through towns
that's close to the size of new york
city he feels for somebody who has to
leave their home
and then when they don't they've created
another problem for not only themselves
but for other people for other
responders that have to go there as well
right now they along with crews from the
clark county fire department are
responding to only medical calls or
small brush fire calls this way the lake
tahoe fire departments can focus on
saving homes for us to be able to come
into their stations and provide them
a little bit of of
a break to get their lives back in order
get reset again to go back and engage in
the wildfire
it's an amazing experience for us but as
the fire spreads they are preparing for
the worst the fires
could be threatening
the homes around here within the next 24
hours we're on high alert where we're at
right now the units are expected to be
there for at least two weeks but that
could change reporting for the newsroom
victoria saha 8 news now
and in a briefing today the clark county
fire department chief says if they need
to send additional crews out they will
but they want to make sure they have
enough staff to handle emergency calls
right here in the valley first